hermione one of any of our plans ever
actually worked
you would never guess that some of the
most iconic moments in the harry potter
films were actually
improvised talk about movie magic when
you bring together
so many talented people like the
incredible cast of harry potter you
inevitably get moments that were never
supposed to happen
that's the beauty of adaptations in the
process of translating the book to
screen and bringing what's on screen to
life
actors improvise lines and moments that
end up feeling totally earned and
natural
from onset accidents to memorable lines
these moments
totally had you fooled into thinking
they were planned all along
i know but it's the only plan we've got
at 13 years old daniel radcliffe was
keeping pace with the best of the best
hard to believe but the tense face-off
between harry and lucius malfoy at the
end of chamber of secrets was improvised
after dumbledore dismisses lucius he's
supposed to leave the room without
another word but jason isaacs ad-libbed
the quip
let us hope harry potter is always
around to save the day
but harry claps back don't worry
i will be it's a pitch perfect moment
that was all daniel radcliffe
fitting two in that harry potter the
character and the story will always be
around
all thanks to the wonderfully dedicated
fans
it's not a term one usually hears in
civilized conversation
sometimes actors are so talented you can
just roll the camera
and capture the magic that ensues that's
exactly what director david yates did
for the scene in deathly hallows part 1
where bellatrix tortures hermione
he had two phenomenal actresses in
helena bonham carter
and emma watson and letting them do
their thing was definitely the right
choice
as much of the scene was improvised to
top it off the most excruciating detail
when bellatrix carves the word
mudblood onto hermione's arm was also
the actress's idea
stop stop stop one of our favorite ron
and hermione moments comes early in the
series
at the end of chamber of secrets the
trio is reunited after hermione was
petrified by the basilisk
leaving us teary-eyed every time the
script had hermione hug
both harry and ron but emma watson was
too nervous to hug them both so she
improvised the wonderfully awkward
handshake with ron it ends up being a
great moment that says so much about
their relationship
the infamous moment when voldemort hugs
malfoy in the deathly hallows was never
in the script
it's such an odd moment for voldemort to
hug malfoy that it could only have been
a spur of the moment choice by the
brilliant ralph finnis
apparently he only did the hug in one of
the takes too but it was so bizarre and
effective that that was the take they
went with for the movie
like all of us watching tom felton
didn't see it coming so his baffled
reaction was totally genuine
dobby feels most aggrieved sir another
great improvised moment is all
thanks to the wonders of technology
jason isaacs started kicking out at thin
air in the scene when lucius leaves
dumbledore's office
to the confusion of chris columbus who
thought he was tripping on something
really he was improvising the moment
when lucius kicks dobby down the stairs
just to add that extra bit of cruelty to
the character
one person couldn't feel all that that
explode
as the trio got older and less innocent
they also started to experience
more tension within the group but they
share a great moment in order of the
phoenix
sitting around the gryffindor common
room discussing harry's love life
hermione explains how cho must be
feeling and quips that rod got the
emotional range of a teaspoon
the laugh that the three share after
emma watson delivers this line was
apparently a genuine laugh
from the actors we're glad they kept it
[Music]
one of the funniest moments in the
movies has to be the moment in chamber
of secrets when malfoy stumbles on ron
and harry who have taken polyjuice
potion to disguise themselves as crab
and goyal
malfoy can't imagine why goyle is
wearing reading glasses
and casually throws out what's a naked
braid
it's all in tom felton's delivery
apparently he'd forgotten his actual
line and
improvise this hilarious bit of dialogue
harry potter
is dead in deathly hallows part 2
voldemort gives a grand speech during
the battle of hogwarts to demonstrate
his power and compel those still
fighting the good
fight to fall in line but surprisingly
the speech
terrifying in its menace wasn't totally
scripted
ralph finn has improvised much of it
changing up his lines each
take to keep the reactions of those
listening fresh according to jason
isaacs it kept a courtyard of extras and
actors on their toes
we bet it did you've got dirt on your
nose by the way
seeing how young the harry potter cast
was back in the first movie makes us
super nostalgic for more innocent times
the trio's first scene together was the
beginning of it all but did you know
that part of the scene was improvised by
emma watson
when hermione realizes she's talking to
the harry potter
she shouts holy cricket you're harry
potter
the holy cricket exclamation was totally
improvised director chris columbus loved
it and kept it in
how do i look exceptionally ordinary
dancing is hard and it's easy to make a
fool of yourself doing it but luna
lovegood
is one person who dances like no one's
watching in the deathly hallows part 1
luna's hilariously odd dance with her
father at bill and fleur's wedding
wasn't scripted
ivana lynch wanted to create a luna
worthy dance to perform for the scene
and what she came up with was so strange
and amazing that we can't imagine the
scene without it
master has given dobby a shark
what i didn't in the script for chamber
of secrets
lucius tries to cast some minor curse on
harry after he helps to free dobby
jason isaacs apparently forgot what
curse he was supposed to say
and said the first thing that came to
mind which happened to be avada kedavra
we'd say going straight to the killing
curse is a bit of an overreaction
thankfully dobby intervenes before he
can finish it the moment works because
it shows how unstable and frightening
lucius can be you shall
not harm harry potter who could forget
mr weasley's super serious question to
harry in chamber of secrets
tell me what exactly is the function of
a rubber duck
this moment was also improvised mark
williams who played arthur weasley came
up with a whole series of funny
muggle-related questions to ask harry in
the scene where they first met
he would change it up each take for
maximum comedic impact
if only we could have been a fly on the
wall while they were filming this scene
there's no hogus without you hagrid at
the end of chamber of secrets
after hagrid has been vindicated he gets
a standing ovation from all of hogwarts
well almost everyone but malfoy and his
crew naturally
but crab apparently didn't get the memo
he stands and claps along with everyone
else before malfoy yanks him back down
but this moment wasn't supposed to
happen apparently the actor who plays
crab
didn't realize what was going on and
stood to clap by accident
chris columbus liked it and decided to
make it part of the scene
the climax of the order of the phoenix
is a tense standoff between dumbledore's
army and the death eaters inside the
ministry of magic
harry's friends are fascinated with
death eaters including the sadistic
bellatrix lestrange
who has neville at wandpoint helena
bottom carter got a little too
into character though apparently bonham
carter jammed her wand into matthew
lewis's ear by accident
but since it was very in character they
left it in the only issue is
she actually perforated lewis's eardrum
ouch
don't play with wands kids
lucius malfoy swoops into the chamber of
secrets with flowing blonde locks
dark wardrobe and iconic slytherin cane
and suddenly
it totally clicks why draco is the way
he is but lucius was originally
described much differently
he's so fully realized by jason isaacs
that you would never suspect it but it's
true
isaac's put his own stamp on the
character and designed the whole look
from platinum blonde head to toe
the wand in the cane was also his idea
we're ready for you now follow me the
scene when the first years enter the
great hall for the first time
and finally see it in all its majesty
was actually the first time that the
actors stepped foot on the great hall
set
so their odd reactions are totally real
of course the floating candles and
magical ceiling were special effects but
it's still a remarkable set
and having the kids react off the cuff
makes the moment that much more magical
[Music]
barty crouch jr is maybe the creepiest
character in the whole series
and that's all thanks to david tennant's
deliciously slimy performance
his snake-like tick of flicking his
tongue only reinforced how much of a
duplicitous death eater he was
interestingly the constant tongue
flicking was improvised by david tennant
it's one of those rare improvisations
that ends up being crucial to the plot
since the characteristic flickering
tongue
is a dead giveaway that mad i moody is
not who he seems
you won because i made it so potter
finally in prisoner of azkaban director
alfonso curon
wanted to add a touch of realism to the
characters who were always in uniform in
the previous two films
so he asked everyone playing hogwarts
students to wear their uniforms however
they liked
that's why you'll notice some students
looking very put together and others
looking disheveled with crooked ties and
untucked shirts
it's that kind of attention to detail
that makes the harry potter movies feel
so real
despite the magic
as you can see spontaneity has a way of
creating the best moments in a movie
were you fooled by any of these scenes
in the harry potter franchise
let us know in the comments and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button for
more magical videos from the things
thanks for watching potterheads mischief
managed